playing the Champions League final on
the Wednesday we lost
we got back on the Friday the Sunday
morning I had to go pick up my boots at
Carrington the training ground to go to
Saint George's park because I was doing
my uh a license coaching back and I went
in at seven o'clock in the morning and I
parked on the back and the his office
lights on and he's there in his chair
I thought oh no I don't want to see him
we've just lost the European Cup final
four four days ago so I drove back
around the front and went and got my
boots and moved out but he was there at
Sunday morning half six seven o'clock
the only person in the building with his
light on four days after we'd won the
European Cup Final and you've been in
his mid-60s I thought no one could live
with that that that's the reason he's
winning that's the reason he's been
there's no other manager no other leader
that I know four days after that defeat
in his off time in the summer is in his
office on a Sunday morning at half past
six